President Trump saying he knows Iran is
responsible for a recent series of
tanker attacks and his Defense
Department providing what it says is
video evidence of course amount of Kevin
Cork is at the White House to show us
tonight good evening Kevin evening bread
the video is if nothing else compelling
that is if what it purports to show is
accurate that the Iranians are in fact
behind a series of attacks on vessels in
the region and that's precisely what the
President believes a happy 73rd birthday
serenade for President Trump at the
White House today but while his
intention in the Rose Garden was trained
on domestic healthcare policy earlier he
took square aim at a familiar
international storyline Iran's
destabilizing behavior
well Iran didn't do it and you know they
did it because you saw the boat I guess
one of the minds didn't explode and it's
probably got essentially Iran written
all over it what Iran did the president
surmise was attack all tankers in the
Gulf of Oman this week evidenced by US
navy footage purportedly showing Iranian
vessels attempting to remove unexploded
ordnance from a tanker that was them and
they didn't want the evidence left
behind I guess they don't know that we
have things that we could detect in the
dark that worked very well not
surprisingly the Iranians rejected the
Americans assertion Iranian Foreign
Minister Javad Zarif said this was proof
of the USS quote Plan B sabotage
diplomacy the incident comes a month
after four oil tankers were damaged in
attacks that the Trump administration
blamed on Iran proof said the president
today of a faltering and increasingly
desperate regime with 14 different sites
of conflict they were in charge of every
single place and they really are they're
a nation of terror and they've changed a
lot since I've been president while some
have suggested continued Iranian
aggression could hasten the drumbeat
toward war president Trump told Fox News
that thanks to his outreach toward Kim
jong-un the u.s. averted a war with
North Korea you know the papers couldn't
believe when we had the first meeting
they couldn't believe
a second you know we never had meetings
we're gonna end up in war if I wasn't
president you would right now be in a
major war with North Korea still a war
of another kind a trade war with China
continues to worry investors across the
globe and with the g20 meetings in Japan
set for later this month the president
today showed little interest in changing
course to make a deal with Beijing it
doesn't matter if he shows up good if he
doesn't in the meantime would take it in
billions of dollars a month Brian from
China well we're good to see eventually
they're gonna make a deal because
they're gonna have to Bret the president
also said there's no way he's going to
fire Kellyanne Conway counselor to the
president despite a recommendation from
a government watchdog group which said
that she's been a repeated violator of
the Hatch Act the president said the
Office of Special Counsel is simply
trying to take away her right to free
speech